so my name is chris uh my username on
social media is program
max uh the way this talk works is kind
of more comfortable if you
feel free to ask questions so you don't
have to wait till the end if you have a
question on a particular slide just go
ahead and raise your hand or
sing and dance whatever you want to do
okay so let's get started
so this is the road map i want to talk
to or talk about today
i doubt we'll have time to cover
everything but that's actually okay
because those last two points
draw pointers and templates you don't
super need to know them right now
and i go into like really ugly details
about them
just to try to make them less scary um
but you know if we don't get to those
slides it's no big deal
just be aware that what i'm going to
show you in those slides you probably
don't want to write in your day-to-day
work
so you know if you go back later and
look at the slides don't use that as an
example
all right so let's start with free
functions so i'm going to pick on java a
little bit and that's not because
java is bad um it's just easiest for
everybody to read
and uh i want to use java as
examples that are clear you know whether
you're coming from python or java or
javascript whatever so here's
uh two cases of pure object orientation
that happened in java
that don't really make a lot of sense so
the first one is
your entry point the static void main
that doesn't actually have to be part of
a class
which is why it's static in the first
place here it's related to class
hello world app but it could have been
in any class so it really proves that
it's not actually
connected to a class at all and further
we never had a chance to create a new
instance of this class
so it couldn't have possibly been
related to the class like there's no
way at all so that was just we had to do
it because
java is pure object oriented
uh same with this the max function to
get two integers
that doesn't have to be a class at all
you know you pass in two integers it
returns the max of the two this has
nothing to do with the class so really
here the class
is just a name space so this is an
example of where
pure object orientation isn't really
perfect for all situations
and if we translate those exact same
things into c plus plus
we wouldn't have done object orientation
we would have just made them free
functions
so that they're free here means not like
free as in speech
or free as in it's no cost performance
it just means it's not related to uh
class
okay include and linkage so java python
you're kind of used to these
import things and the idea is some other
file has it let's go fetch it from that
other file
it's the same concept in c plus plus
you'll notice i kind of did pairs here
so
the top one is sort of like getting a
system library sort of thing
and the bottom one is here is some of
our code
and in c plus you typically do those a
little differently if it's like a
library you're probably going to be
using those angles
and if it's your own thing you'll
probably be using quotes
this is roughly how c plus plus
is built so i'll have two code files
a dot cbp and b dot cpb each of them are
individually set to or sent to an
instance of a compiler
and compiled completely independent of
each other
so each of these is called a translation
unit
and then the result of that compile is
an object file
all the object files are then gathered
up together and sends to the linker
the linker combines them and makes the
program for you
so that kind of results in there being a
compile phase and a link
phase and i'm saying kind of here
because the lines get a little bit
blurred
um there are times when you do link time
optimization
where it'll actually the compiler passes
extra info over to the linker and then
the linker can start rearranging
functions how it wants
but this is roughly how you'd want to
think about it
so by default because we had sort of
separate
translation units and they don't know
anything about each other by default
there's no way for the functions or
classes or whatever in your files
to actually interact and we probably
want to interact with them
we'll get to that in a second but
remember that linker is going to combine
all these things
and maybe some of the functions i'm
writing i don't want to expose
to the other uh translation units when
they get combined maybe this one was
supposed to stay
just within this file so there's two
ways of
hiding it from other translation units
one is to put
your function in an anonymous namespace
like this
and the other is just to put static in
the front static is kind of the old way
we prefer the
anonymous namespace in chrome
so i mentioned that if you have two
separate code files you probably want to
you know use functions from the other
one or the class from the other one
so the way that works is you'll have for
example compute
harmony.cpp and you pair it with
computeharmony.h that's the header file
for the actual translation unit
and in the header file you're going to
be doing forward declares
of what you want to expose so for
example if i have some function compute
harmony i'll say
in the dot h file hey i promise there's
a function called
compute harmony you just have to trust
me on it and at length time
the linker will know where the function
is and it'll finish the
call but in your code if you
try to call this function you can just
trust me that the function will exist
eventually
at link phase so
uh so here's what that would look like
we have our dot h file all it does
is forward declare there will be a
function this is what the signature
looks like
then we have the cpp file it includes
the dot h file just to make sure the
forward declare
and the actual function link up
and then that's where you put the actual
function body and then in the other
cpp file you also include that same.h
file
so when we're compiling it doesn't know
what function it's going to call it just
knows what the function should look like
but at length time it'll know what the
actual function is going to be
any questions so far great okay
so back to our little picture this is
kind of what it'll look like now
we used to have a dot cpp and b dot cpp
well now we're going to pair
a and a dot h
sorry not compare um combined whatever
okay so then we mentioned there's the
two ways of including there's with
quotes if it's our own
file and then there's the angles if it's
like a system file
um that happens at a preprocessor step
before the actual like meet of c plus
happens
so what this ends up doing is
effectively
copying and pasting so it'll go open
that file
copy the whole content of the file and
then paste it on the line
that was including it it's not 100 true
but that's like 99
true okay
so we're going to run into a little
problem with this copy paste
thing and i need to set up a scenario to
show you what this problem is going to
be
so previously we were just doing a
forward declare of a function
you're allowed to forward declare the
same function 20 times if you want
that's okay
but a define is different from a
declaration
a define is saying this is the actual
thing and you can't redefine something
so if i have my header file and i put
this class
music type in it this is now a
definition of that class
it's not just a declaration that there
will be a class
so now i have jazz dot h and it includes
music type dot h
and i also have classical.h and it also
includes musictype.h
and then i have playmusic.cpp if that
includes both
jazz and classical we kind of created a
diamond
where we've included this musictype.h
twice in this file and then that means
this class has been
defined twice so the compiler will yell
at us and say well you're not allowed to
redefine classes even if they're the
exact same
i don't know they're the same yet so
it'll yell at us
so we need some way to protect from this
so what we do is uh oh actually i
already described all that so what we do
is this uh ford excuse me
um what's it called protect
uh inclusion guards that's what it's
called so
if the file name is musictype.h you just
do this if not defined
musictype.h define musictype.h which
means
the very first time it'll enter this but
the second
and third time it'll hit that oh it it
has been defined we don't want to do
this whole thing
a second time so that's kind of the
standard c plus plus thing you see this
in all of the header files
and it protects from that multiple
inclusion
okay destructors and scope so
imagine we're in java land and we have a
class that represents
some sort of resource like a network
connection or database connection
file something like that
we don't have deterministic destruction
in java which means if i am currently
using this
file and then i'm done with it i get rid
of my reference
the reference is still in memory until
garbage collection happens
i don't know when garbage collection is
going to happen it might never happen
and so i don't actually know when the
destructor is going to get called
so it may never actually release the
resource
so that's kind of a problem um
java offers us this finalize
um oh and by the way that's you know i
could have called dot close on it but
what if i forget
you would rather have this automatic
protection that as soon as i'm done
using it it automatically cleans it up
so we could add this you know finalize
overload but that kind of runs into the
same situation i don't know when it's
going to be finalized i don't know when
the garbage collector
collector is going to come so that's not
really solving the problem
c sharp added the using keyword and then
java 7
added automatic resource management and
that gives you a way to say like
within this range of code
i'm going to use this resource and when
i'm done i want you to garbage collect
just that resource
so it kind of solves this problem kind
of
but now we have a separate problem and
it's actually kind of similar
the responsibility is on me to use this
using keyword
and if i forget i've fallen back into
the same issue
it's the exact same as if i had
forgotten to call dot close
so we didn't really solve the problem
here
so that's where c plus plus destructors
come in these are deterministic
so this is an example of a destructor
you can put whatever code you want in
there to clean up your resource
and as soon as that object is destroyed
if it goes out of scope or anything like
that
this destructor is going to be called
uh so for example if i have a function
and then
i you know that's my class that i have
as soon as we hit the closing bracket
here
or brace this is going to call all the
destructors for all the objects
in that function
and you can actually just insert these
wherever you want to like force like
local destruction
so that way it gets cleaned up between
the first part and the second part
so the idea here is anytime you want to
represent a resource
you now have the ability to do that uh
you know i gave examples network
connection
file gpu is the one i'm going to use
because that
is less likely to throw an exception and
in chrome code we don't use exceptions
so it kind of fits the slides better
for this next topic raii
so i just showed you that destruction
lets us represent a resource
deterministic destruction does um if we
construct an object while taking
uh that resource now the entire object
is an actual representation of that
resource
so r-a-i-i means resource
acquisition is initialization the idea
being that
if we have constructed this object it is
initialized it's ready to go
so this is old code that you might have
seen
this is the opposite of our aii
so we have a gpu instance and we call
dot open to get this gpu
and that dot open call may have failed
and then we have to call well if it
fails
you know do some error handling this is
the opposite of
raii because we
tried to acquire the resource but we
failed it you know
the initialization isn't acquisition or
acquiring
so this is the opposite of what we want
a better way would be to have like a
function that
always succeeds and it just returns an
instance of our gpu class
and now we don't have to track did it
fail did it not
in this function it will always succeed
the class itself doesn't need to know
if it could have failed and
if we didn't have the option for it to
always succeed like maybe it could have
failed
let's not store it in the class let's
use something like base optional
uh base optional will either be the
class you wanted it to be
or nothing and so that way our gpu class
doesn't have to track
did i fail to initialize
okay pass by reference and value this
one's a little weird because
a lot of other languages
they try to with garbage collection and
all that they try to manage this for you
you don't really get a clear view of
what is a reference and what isn't
a reference so i'm going to continue
picking on java
i love it but you know it's really good
for examples
we have this function add to dictionary
and we pass in
a word makes sense right
in if this was c plus plus that would be
passed by value and what would happen is
when we call this function
it would make a copy of the word that
you passed in
and then inside our function we'd be
operating on that copy
not the original value which means we
can make changes and all that
remember i told you about destructors
are called when the scope is closed
as soon as we leave that function our
copy is destroyed
that's how it would work if we had
written it that way
the alternative to that it's the exact
same thing except we put a little
ampersand
after our type you know add to
dictionary word
ampersand that is saying i'm not
actually taking
a word i'm taking a reference to a word
so in this case if you call this
function
and you pass in some word we are getting
the reference to the original thing and
any changes we make
will actually be reflected in the
original object
this is actually pretty close to how
java works
in java even though we would have typed
the other thing behind the scenes it's
passing references around
so when we want to use this um imagine
our word
class is really heavy it's really
expensive to make copies
you don't want to make hundreds of
copies as you make hundreds of function
calls
and so you might be passing references
around
the opposite of that idea is if it's
really cheap to copy
the reference actually is an indirection
it says here's
the location in memory jump to that
location in memory and then get the
actual thing you wanted
so that extra indirection that's not
free so if it was cheap to copy
like say an integer or something like
that you might as well have just copied
oh another thing i really want to point
out just because it's a reference that
does not make it
memory safe this is not garbage
collected it's
just a pointer that's it
okay so in the last slide it was a word
reference
i'm gonna change that now it's a const
word reference
what that means is the thing that i'm
referencing
i don't want to actually change because
remember it had the option to alter the
outside value
we probably don't want that if we're
just adding it to a dictionary so we can
just throw the const keyword in there
that's pretty typical of old style c
plus plus and this actually started
changing in c block plus 11.
i don't remember if these slides get to
that or not
okay so here are those three examples
that i gave before
and i want to give a general guideline
of when to use which so
the first one const reference if you
don't plan to ever change it and if it's
kind of heavy to copy
go with that um a better way to say that
is if
you're just going to observe the value
that's when you use it
if you're doing a normal reference
non-const
that is if you want to modify the thing
that they are
passing it so if you want to say like
[Music]
initialize all of these values or
something
uh and then the last one when you don't
pass a conference at all is
either it's really cheap to copy the
object or
in new style sql plus if you're
potentially taking
ownership of that object so for example
if somebody says
i'm totally done with this i'm not going
to use it anymore i'm handing it off to
you
it's now your responsibility if i'm the
function who's taking that
thing handed off to me i'm potentially
taking ownership
and that's when i might do this
okay the standard library we're almost
to our
ugly section we're going there
so most languages i've been picking on
java java has a fantastic standard
library it gives you
so much functionality there's sockets
there's
everything in c plus plus we have almost
nothing in the standard library it is
itty bitty and that's actually kind of c
plus plus's
uh weak point and it's getting better
but you know we're still decades behind
so traditionally the solution to this is
we use
separate libraries something else if we
need to socket we go find a socket
library
the standard library is huge despite me
just saying how tiny it is it's tiny
compared to java which is
astronomical but despite it being huge
i only want to focus on three things for
now because i don't have a ton
of time so i want to talk about string
vector and smart pointers
string you're familiar with that you
know i would say std for standard
string dog name equals fido vector is
just a way to have some contiguous
memory
and it's kind of like uh i don't want to
use the word
list but it's just an array it's closer
to an array but it can dynamically grow
and shrink as needed
so here i have a standard vector of
integers and i'll just initialize it one
two three four
and then i could also kind of combine
these i have a standard vector
of strings so now i'm containing the
names
amy and trick
so although i'm only showing you these
three things
there's another piece of the standard
that is actually not widely used but we
should all be using it a lot more
i think this is because uh if we took c
plus plus class in college or
something we were all asked write this
function that's going to loop over this
stuff and do these operations
and so we got used to writing the thing
that's actually already written
for example there's a standard sort
people don't use it for some reason i
don't know why
same with standard copy if so you can
pass in a delegate
or sorry a predicate and say uh
if the value passes my predicate my test
if i want it to be like values less than
10 or something
if it passes the predicate then copy
otherwise don't
um so you know there's a whole bunch of
things in the standard
algorithms not just these standard
containers
but people don't use them often so i
encourage you if you want to look like a
really smart c plus plus programmer
start using standard algorithms
people will be impressed all right smart
pointers
so you've maybe heard about pointer oh
question
yes uh there is a website
cppreference.com
it is fantastic it goes over everything
including like
this function was added in c plus 11 but
before it you had this other function
instead
so that website contains everything
about the language
the standard and it's broken down into
chunks where you can sort of navigate
to where you want great question
okay show of hands who here has heard of
pointers in c plus plus and heard like
horror stories or like battle scars or
something
everybody okay i wasn't expecting it to
be that much
okay so you get the idea they're
terrifying um
so smart pointers aren't those those are
raw pointers and we'll get the
that section later smart pointers are
sort of
like let's stop terrifying each other
so in a garbage collected language
you're familiar with you know if i
have a reference the thing stays alive
and i can have multiple references
and it's still going to be alive until
the very last reference goes away
then the garbage collector has a chance
to come and clean that up
in c plus plus that would be a standard
shared pointer
and you get that from include memory so
this represents like if the object
lifetime
should actually be managed by multiple
things
this is where i need to sort of tell you
to be different from what you're used to
if you're used to a garbage collected
language you don't worry about who
owns the lifetime it's just whoever has
a reference but in c
plus plus you really want it to be like
this
object should only live between here and
there and then it should have that
deterministic destruction
and so uh a shared pointer a shared
lifetime is actually a really uncommon
situation
even though that's the default in
garbage collected languages
that's weird typically like my car has
wheels it's not like
well if my car goes away i still have
wheels that doesn't make sense
so we have this but we don't really use
it that often you try to avoid it if you
can
in fact if you have to use it you start
questioning like did i do something
wrong
um and although i'm showing you standard
shared pointer we actually don't use
that in chrome
we use base shared ref it's basically
the same thing though
uh okay yeah and i told you that most of
the time we don't actually want to use a
standard shared pointer
so the alternative to shared pointer is
unique pointer
makes sense there's only one owner it is
unique
and you can't make copies of a unique
pointer obviously because then you would
have
multiples and duplicates and shared
ownership so what you can do is
move it and remember earlier when i said
if i'm taking ownership of something
somebody could call my function and pass
me ownership of this
pointer and that would still be unique
if they no longer
have this ownership so it's all sort of
tying together
um and then yeah when the only reference
is destroyed the actual object is
destroyed so it's kind of like
a garbage collected language where you
can only have one reference at a time
that's kind of how it would
work
okay and i mentioned you know you can't
actually make a copy
but you can pass ownership the way you
pass ownership is with
standard move std move up there that is
a way to say
i'm completely done with this i'm going
to pass it off to somebody else
and if you want to learn more about this
standard move and the whole
like passing ownership uh here at google
we have a class for c plus
11 where we cover this or later today
i'll be giving a talk called c plus plus
memory
but if you look at your um badges
i changed the title late and on your
badge it'll actually say c
plus 201 move semantics
so you can learn more about it then
[Music]